well during yesterday's briefing dr
fauci also said we might be seeing a
plateau when it comes to the average
number of new coronavirus cases every
week
but a newer strain of the virus first
found in the uk has now been identified
in at least
20 different states yikes dr fauci says
that strain
and the new variant discovered in south
africa are more transmissible
but they may not be deadlier our dr
david agust joins us now to discuss that
let's start right away with that david
because
i like the not deadlier part but the
more transistor
more transmissible is a little
disconcerting can you explain what is
happening here what this means
so what happened is the virus the spike
protein has changed and the spike
proteins how it gets into
our cells and it's binding more tightly
so in
the beginning of the pandemic the first
10 11 months
say it took 10 minutes of a conversation
four feet apart for me to give enough
particles to you to spread the virus
now that number is half or a third
and so much more transmissible
smaller amounts of time smaller amounts
of particles i can transmit you the
virus
that's what gets us very scary this
plateau we're seeing now may start to
take off
as this variant becomes dominant across
the country so why is this popping up
now is this a common thing with these
kind of viruses
well yeah i mean these viruses change
over a million years our genome changed
one percent
these viruses can change one percent in
a day but for the first
10 months we were slowly getting
infected in the country now
30 percent of the country is infected
and we're starting to vaccinate so we
are changing so the virus is changing in
return
and what we're seeing is get more
aggressive in terms of being able to be
more infectious
the clinical outcome's the same i mean
you're not going to get sicker with this
variant but it's easier to catch
do you think the vaccines everybody's
excited about the vaccine everyone's
trying to get it
will it be effective against this new
variant strain
i am so excited about the vaccine i mean
i literally am in tears every day if i
get a note from a patient i got it
um what we know is the uk variant the
carrying from england
the vaccines work efficiently again but
the south african variant is the real
worrisome one
many of the monoclonal antibodies which
die into a tiny part of the spike
protein
aren't binding and what we're seeing
with some of the people who've been
vaccinated we've been exposed to the
prior versions of the virus
is that their antibodies aren't binding
well so we don't know the true answer
yet there'll be some immunity
but probably not a hundred percent
immunity like we see with the vaccines
with the other strains
what do you think of what you're hearing
so far david about the biden plan
to attack covet
100 million doses a hundred days you
know i like putting
a stick in the ground i think he's going
to dramatically exceed that if we look
at the supply of vaccines coming
from modernizer jnj and astrazeneca i
think he may be able to do 200 million
in the first 100 days so
that part i'm excited about there's a
real strategic plan for every aspect
of fighting this virus of going on
offense in the country
if we all follow if we stop the spread
of the virus and this plant takes act
we're going to get by summer some
thing toward herd immunity and hopefully
get a more normal fall
how likely is that dr fauci said the
other day 75 to 80 percent
if we if we get the vaccine we could
have 75 to 80 percent herd immunity
listen it's doable right but what we got
to do is roll it out many states
have half the vaccine sitting in freezer
i seen in a freezer and not an
arm yeah to me it's unconscionable we
have to do better
and we have to get more aggressive in
getting this vaccine out
and the question i have to ask you about
dr fauci because he seemed downright
giddy yesterday at that press conference
even used the word liberating what do
you make of his change and attitude did
you understand his
apparently i love it you know the
conversations i have now
with the administration they're about
science data
people talking back to me in a new new
way
i i mean i'm giddy i think everybody who
is fighting this virus is feeling a new
sense of optimism
and to be part of a team that really
gets it
all right dr david agus thank you we
like people who get it very much
thanks a lot